the fight between Sony and Disney /
spider-man still continues and right now
we're not really sure when or where it's
going to end how's it going everybody
it's worn and there is a lot of talk
right now about what exactly is going on
between Disney and Sony there's a lot of
different reports out there but right
now as it stands Kevin Feige is not
going to be involved with spider-man
moving forward according to an official
statement from Sony yesterday and
although there is still hope that Sony
and Disney can come to some sort of an
agreement a question that everybody has
been asking is how exactly does Tom
Holland Phil about this now we've gotten
reactions from people such as Tom
Hollands father and Jeremy Renner who of
course plays Hawkeye both wanting to
save Spidey from leaving the MCU but
again how does Tom actually feel about
everything because Marvel is actually
the studio that casted him as Spider Man
Marvel specifically casted Tom Holland
as spider-man in the MCU to play
spider-man in Captain America Civil War
he was casted by Kevin Feige Amy Pascal
and the Russo brothers as well and
although Tom Holland has not issued an
official statement yet he has reacted to
this situation and will talk about it
but first if you'd like a chance to win
an Xbox one or a ps4 be sure to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment with your favorite superhero
or villain so you can enter my giveaway
I'm picking a winner at 500,000
subscribers so again a few people have
commented on the situation one of which
is Tom's father he tweeted out hashtag
save spider-man and then he linked to
his blog where he talked about how he
hopes Sony and Disney can come to an
agreement and then Jeremy Renner who
plays Hawkeye in the Avengers posted a
photo on Instagram saying hey at Sony
Pictures we want spider-man back to the
real Stan Lee and Marvel please thank
you hashtag Congrats
hashtag spider-man rocks hashtag a bow
and arrow and hashtag please so there's
an Avenger on spider-man's side and
again although Tom Holland has not
issued an official statement it does
seem like he has had a reaction as he
has unfollowed Sony on Instagram now
this comes from multiple reports from
multiple websites comicbook.com heroic
hollywood.com ign.com MCU cosmic comm if
you google search Tom Holland unfollow
Sony you'll find multiple reports and
then if you go to Instagram you can see
that he has fall
Marvel Studios but is in fact not
following Sony Pictures
so if Tom Holland truly did unfollow
Sony which seems to be the case and
which is being reported from multiple
different sources he is clearly very
upset about the fact that Disney and
Sony cannot come to an agreement so Tom
Holland is really in an unfortunate
situation again he was cast by Marvel to
play a spider-man specifically in the
MCU and now if Sony and Disney can't
come to an agreement he will no longer
be playing spider-man in the MCU but on
his own so in the next spider-man movie
there would be no MCU characters no
Avengers no happy hogan nobody but again
there is hope that Sony and Disney can
reach some sort of an agreement so
spider-man can stay in the MCU again if
I hear anything I will definitely report
it and keep everybody up to date but let
me know what you think about these
reports of Tom Holland unfollowing Sony
on Instagram also don't forget to
comment with your favorite superhero or
villain like this video and subscribe to
my channel so you can enter my giveaway
and stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU don't forget to
follow me on Twitter and Instagram and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof